[Music] we want to show you something
on the monitor here quick question why
is tanv in just the tanv picture
I saw that on the iPad earlier can
you do your best Brandon T of head
shot impression can I yeah I have
to Crazy [Music] Eyes oh wow I like this
there that's crazy all [Music]
right I'm not pretending to be Brandon
Tana boys I always thought you remind
me of uh Steve Bui Mr Deeds right there can
you do an impression of those nope yeah I can
try I don't have that flow or that facial hair
for this but I guess it's just [Music] like I
scarred like 700 people whoever watched that
just terrified now is that good that close
those eyes get [Music] wide
practice that's
brutal it's definitely better than
his [Music]
n